GOING TO TRY TO EXPLAIN IT.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
WE ARE NOT OVERSTATING IT.
FIRST, KANYE WEST SPOKE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND DREW NEWS
COVERAGE FOR WHAT HE SAID.
COMMENTATORS WERE NOT IMPRESS
AND MANY DISMISSED IT AS A
SIDE SHOW.
IN SOME WAYS THEY WERE RIGHT.
HE MADE A NUMBER OF
INTERESTING POINTS BUT IN THE
END HE IS AN ENTERTAINER.
DONALD TRUMP WAS THERE, TOO.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, THE MOST
POWERFUL MAN IN THE WORLD.
LIKE THE REST OF US ULTIMATELY
HE IS PASSING THROUGH.
THERE WILL BE OTHER
PRESIDENTS.
THE QUESTION TO CARE ABOUT IS
BIGGER THAN TWO PEOPLE.
IS AMERICA STILL A FREE
COUNTRY?
CAN PEOPLE OPENLY EXPRESS
BELIEFS IN PUBLIC?
ARE THEY STILL ALLOWED TO SAY
WHAT THEY THINK IS TRUE
WITHOUT BEING PUNISHED FOR IT?
THAT IS WHAT MATTERS MOST AND
MATTERS MORE THAN ANY SINGLE
POLITICIAN OR RAPPER OR
MIDTERM ELECTION.
BY THAT STANDARD THE ONE THAT
MATTERS WHAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TELLS US A LOT ABOUT AMERICA
RIGHT NOW.
MUCH OF IT OMINOUS.
IF YOU MISSED IT, HERE IS PART
OF WHAT KANYE WEST SAID.
>> PEOPLE EXPECT IF YOU ARE
BLACK YOU HAVE TO BE DEMOCRAT.
I HAVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WELFARE IS WHY BLACK PEOPLE
ARE DEMOCRATS.
FIRST, LIMIT TO THE AMOUNT OF
JOBS.
SO THE FATHERS LOSE JOB AND WE
WILL GIVE YOU MORE FOR HAVING
MORE KIDS IN YOUR HOME.
>> Tucker: TO SUM UP, KANYE
WEST SAYS THAT THE LIBERAL
SOCIAL PROGRAMS UNDERMUNE THE
BLACK FAMILY.
HE NOTES THAT THE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS FACE
ENORMOUS PRESSURE NOT TO
SUPPORT REPUBLICANS.
HE SUGGESTED THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OFTEN
DISPLAYS UNDISGUISED CONTEMPT
FOR MEN AND MASCULINITY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT,ITE
KNOWS ESPECIALLY CONTROVERSIAL
STATEMENTS.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY TRUE FOR
ONE THING.
IF YOU PAY ANY ATTENTION AT
ALL YOU ALREADY KNOW THAT.
WHAT WEST SAID IS HARD TO
REBUT FACTUALLY THAT NOBODY
TRIED TO DO THAT.
INSTEAD THEY ATTACKED HIM AS A
PERSON.
ATTACKED HIS DECENCY AND HIS
MENTAL CONDITION.
IF THAT SOUNDS FAMILIAR, IT'S
BECAUSE THIS IS NOW A
UNIVERSAL TACTIC ON THE LEFT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO ARGUE WITH
YOU.
THEY WANT TO DENOUNCE YOU.
WATCH THIS CNN DEEP CRITIQUE
OF TRUMP'S DOMESTIC PROGRAM.
>> WHY DOESN'T PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONDEMN RACISM?
HIS OWN WORDS AND ACTION TELL
YOU WHY.
HE IS RACIST.
LET ME NOT MINCE WORDS.
THIS PRESIDENT TRAFFICS IN
RACIST.
ROSEANN'S TWEET WAS RACIST BUT
HE FAILED TO CONDEMN IT.
WHY?
HE CAN'T.
HIS OWN WORDS AND ACTIONS ARE
RACIST, TOO.
WE HAVE TO STOP PRETENDING
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT, THAT HE IS NOT
EMBOLDENING RACISTS AND
RACISM.
>> Tucker: THE BEST THING
ABOUT THE ARGUMENT IS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO LEARN ANYTHING.
MASTER ANY DETAILS BECAUSE
FACTS ARE IRRELEVANT.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS MY
OPPONENTS ARE BAD PEOPLE.
YOU MUST IGNORE THEM.
SO IT WASN'T OBVIOUS HOW THE
LEFT WAS GOING TO PULL ANY OF
THIS ALL WITH KANYE WEST.
THEY ATTACKED HIM AS CRAZY AT
FIRST BUT IT DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE.
IF YOU THINK THAT KANYE WEST
IS MENTALLY HILL WHY ARE YOU
ATTACKING HIM FOR THAT?
YOU CAN'T CALL HIM RACE
U.S. BECAUSE HE IS BLACK --
RACIST BECAUSE HE IS BLACK.
BUT THEN THEY CRACK THE CODE.
YOU MUST IGNORE KANYE WEST, HE
EXPLAINS TO THE REST OF US
BECAUSE HE IS A TRAITOR TO HIS
RACE.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT I SAW WAS A MENTAL
SHOW TODAY.
HIM IN FRONT OF THE WHITE
PEOPLE, MOSTLY WHITE PEOPLE
EMBARRASSING HIMSELF.
EMBARRASSING AMERICANS BUT
MOSTLY AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN HE IS THE
PERSON WHO REPRESENTS THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY?
HE DOESN'T.
THIS WAS AN EMBARRASSMENT.
HIS MOTHER IS ROLLING OVER IN
HER GRAVE.
>> Tucker: THERE YOU GO.
THAT HIS SKIN COLOR MEANS HE
IS REQUIRED TO BEHAVE IN A
VERY SPECIFIC WAY.
IF HE CHOOSES TO BEHAVE IN ANY
OTHER WAY HE SHOULD BE
PUNISHED.
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO DON
LEMON, HIS RACE IS HIS DESTINY
AND IT DEFINES EVERYTHING
ABOUT HIM.
PEOPLE USED TO TALK LIKE THIS
50 YEARS AGO AS THEY DEFENDED
RACIAL SEGREGATION OF THE
AMERICAN SOUTH.
WHAT A SURPRISE TO LEARN THEY
ARE STILL TALKING THAT WAY.
THIS TIME IT'S ON CNN.
MICHAEL ERIC DIESON WENT EVEN
FURTHER.
FOR THE CRIME OF BEING
FRIENDLY WITH A POLITICIAN HE
DOESN'T LIKE, HE SAYS KANYE
WEST IS ACTUALLY DESPITE ALL
APPEARANCES A PRACTICING WHY
WHY -- WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> WE SHOULD SAY KANYE AS
AFRICAN-AMERICAN PEOPLE CANNOT
STAND IDLY BY WHY YOU GIVE
COVER TO A MAN WHO IS A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
THIS IS WHITE SUPREMACIST BY
VENTRILOQUISM.
WHITE RACIST IDEALS FLOWING
FROM KANYE WEST'S MOUTH.
>> Tucker: KEEP IN MIND THEY
ARE CALLING WEST THE CRAZY
ONE.
THEY DON'T MEAN IT.
THEY WOULDN'T BE SO ANGRY IF
THEY DID MEAN IT.
THE REAL FEAR IS THAT WEST
ISN'T CRAZY AT A AND YOU MIGHT
LISTEN TO HIM.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WEST OR
TRUMP.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER.
MOST THINGS ARE.
SUDDENLY A SMALL NUMBER OF THE
IDEOLOGICAL GATEKEEPERS
CONTROL WHAT EVERYBODY ELSE IN
THIS COUNTRY IS ALLOWED TO SAY
AND THINK.
THE PEOPLE WORK AT GOOGLE,
CNN, IN THE U.S. SENATE AND
MAYBE DOWN THE HALL FROM THE
OFFICE.
IN THE CORPORATE SENSITIVITY
DEPARTMENT.
THEY ARE ENJOYING THE POWER
THEY HAVE BECAUSE PEOPLE
ALWAYS ENJOY HAVING POWER.
BUT THEY ARE WORRIED.
THEY CAN KNOW THEY CAN ONLY
MAINTAIN THE SYSTEM, THE ONE
THEY BENEFIT FROM THROUGH FEAR
AND LYING.
IF ENOUGH PEOPLE TO DECIDE TO
IGNORE THE RULES AND THINK FOR
THEMSELVES THIS IS OVER.
THEY HAVE NO MORE POWER.
WHOLE COUNTRY OF PEOPLE SAYING
WHAT THEY THINK IS TRUE.
THAT IS THE NIGHTMARE AND WHAT
THEY FEAR THE MOST.
I COULD START WITH A SINGLE
PERSON.
WRAPPER SPEAKING STREAM OF
CONSCIOUSNESS IN THE OVAL
OFFICE ONE AFTERNOON.
FROM THERE, WHO KNOWS WHERE IT
COULD GO?
OTHER PEOPLE COULD STOP HIDING
THE UNAPPROVED OPINIONS.
THIS IS A TERRIFYING PROSPECT.
FREE SPEECH IS LIKE A VIRUS.
BETTER TO STOP IT WHILE YOU
CAN.
DON LEMON IS NO GENIUS BUT HE
UNDERSTANDS THAT.
MURDOCH IS A CONTRIBUTING
EDITOR AT NATIONAL REVIEW
ONLINE AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHAT ARE THEY REALLY SAYING
ABOUT KANYE WEST?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
UNLIKE BACK IN THE 1960s IN
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT YOU MAY
RECALL A NUMBER OF PROTESTERS
HOLDING UP THE SIGNS SAYING,
"I AM A MAN."
HE IS NOT ABLE TO SAY THAT.
HE SAYS I AM NOT A MAN, I AM
NOT ALLOWED TO THINK ON MY
OWN.
I MUST DO WHAT THE LOCAL
ORTHODOXY SAYS.
SO HE DIDN'T DO THAT SO THEY
ARE DENOUNCED HIM AS A NEGRO.
THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
YOU COME ON EVERY NIGHT AND
PEOPLE SAY YOU ARE WRONG BUT
NOBODY SAYS YOU ARE A BAD
WHITE PERSON.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THEY DISAGREE WITH YOUR
VIEWS BUT THEY THEY HEART
ATTACK AIM AS A HUMAN BEING
AND TRY TO REMOVE HIS
BLACKNESS FROM HIM.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE NOT EVEN
TREATING HIM AS A HUMAN.
THEY ARE TREATING HIM AS
INTERCHANGEABLE PIECE OF A
LARGER WHOLE.
LIKE A FACENESS DRONE WHO HAS
TO OBEY.
>> HE HAS FALLEN OUT OF LINE.
THEY CAN'T HAVE THAT.
THE FEAR IS PEOPLE LISTEN AND
ASK QUESTIONS ISN'T IT
INTERESTING TO HAVE A
PRESIDENT THAT BROUGHT BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT TO LOWEST LEVEL
OF HISTORY.
GROWING TWICE WHERE IT WAS TWO
YEARS AGO.
SUDDENLY THE BLACK FOLKS THINK
MAYBE HE IS WORKING OUT AND
THE POLICIES AREN'T RACIST
ATTACK WE HEARD ABOUT THEY
MIGHT TO VOTE THAT WAY.
DEMOCRATS WILL BE IN BUG
TROUBLE.
IT -- WILL BE IN BIG TROUBLE.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO
DEHUMANIZE HIM WHICH IS WHAT
THE LEFT IS DOING TONIGHT.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU SEEN
THIS?
AM I MISREMEMBERING?
I DON'T REMEMBER PEOPLE TERMS
THAT ARE UGLY AND I'M NOT
GOING TO REPEAT THEM.
PEOPLE DIDN'T USED TO TALK
LIKE THAT IN TELEVISION UNTIL
RECENTLY.
>> NOT SO MUCH.
NOT TO THIS LEVEL.
UNIFORMLY AND CONSISTENTLY
ACROSS ANY NUMBER OF THE CABLE
CHANNELS, THE VARIOUS PEOPLE
COMING OUT.
THE PROFESSOR DYSON FROM MY
ALMA MATER SAYING THE THINGS
THAT HE IS THAT KANYE IS A
WHITE PREM SUPREMACIST AND
VENTRILOQUIST AND TRUMP IS
PULLING HIS STRINGS.
IF TRUMP WERE A WHITE
SUPREMACIST WHY WOULD WE HAVE
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BLACK
ARTISTS IN THE OVAL OFFICE?
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
IT'S NOT LOGICAL.
THIS SHOWS THE TREMENDOUS
DESPERATION OF WHICH THE
DEMOCRATIC LEFT FIND ITSELF
TODAY.
>> Tucker: IT'S INTERESTING
THE LEVEL OF BULLYING THAT
GOES ON.
IF THEY THOUGHT HE WAS CRAZY,
THEY ARE SAYING HE IS CRAZY
AND IT'S OKAY NOW TO MOCK
PEOPLE'S MENTAL ILLNESS.
BUT IF THEY THOUGHT HE WAS OUT
OF HIS MIND THEY WOULD SMILE
INDULGENTLY LIKE YOU DO WITH
THE GUY EATING IMAGINARY
INSECTS ON THE BUS.
RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
HE TALKED ABOUT JOB CREATION
AND IMPROVING THE ECONOMY AND
THE CRIME DISASTER IN CHICAGO.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE MONTESSORI
SCHOOLS.
HE HAD SOLID THINGS TO SAY IN
THERE.
HE MADE A POINT WHERE IS IT
WRITTEN IF YOU ARE BLACK YOU
HAVE TO BE A DEMOCRAT?
HE IS BREAKING AWAY FROM THE
NOTION.
IF ENOUGH BLACKS BREAK AWAY
FROM THAT NOTION THE DEMOCRATS
WILL BE IN BAD STATE BECAUSE
BLACKS ARE A LARGE PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE.
IF EIGHT OUT OF TEN BLACK
FOLKS STAYED DEMOCRAT AND TWO
OUT OF TEN VOTE REPUBLICANS
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD BE LIKE
THE WHIG PARDON AND THEY WOULD
BE GONE.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE OPINIONS
AND I CERTAINLY HAVE THEM ON
FULL DISPLAY.
WOULDN'T YOUR CONSCIENCE ACHE
A LITTLE IF YOU FOUND YOURSELF
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT REPEATING
NASTIEST TALKING POINT ON
BEHALF OF A POLITICAL PARTY
AND PRETENDING YOU WERE A
JOURNALIST.
WOULD YOU DO THAT?
>> I PRESENT OPINIONS AND I
TRY TO BACK THEM UP WITH THE
FACTS AND THE FIGURES AND THE
QUOTES AND EVIDENCE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT DOING
THAT.
THEY SCREAM TRUMP IS A RACIST.
A RACIST, A RACIST.
WHERE IS THE PROOF?
IF HE WERE RACIST WHY DID HE
CAMPAIGN IN HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
WELCOME THEM WITH AN OFFICE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE TO ASSIST
THEM?
HE MADE M.L.K. BIRTHPLACE
NATIONAL HISTORICAL MONUMENT.
OBAMA COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID THAT.
IT'S NOT BEHAVIOR TO SEE OUT
OF A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE SAYING
WHAT THEY THINK THEY HAVE TO.
THIS IS REMARKABLE THE HACKS
THEY ARE.
>> AND CRUEL.
>> Tucker: I'M AGREE.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
KANYE WEST BUT IT'S MEAN.
TOO MEAN.